[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
right
hey guys this Miguel concepción with
Eric Tay I'm sure some of you guys have
just watched me play the Nier automata
yep DLC and now we are shifting gears to
neo it's a it's like a dlc day i guess a
good job on year earlier did you guys
end i didn't watch the whole thing did
you guys end up fighting the ceos at all
or no no okay gotcha anyways there is a
new region i was able to get to this
because i guess you had to beat the game
right to get to this new region i
believe because i couldn't find it on
yours way of the strong is my new game+
so i went back to where the samurai and
here's this new region king give us a
little bit more gameplay thank you
alright here we're going to start this
off hopefully should play something here
in a second you can bump it up even more
a little bit thank you sir
also we are uh miguel will be watching a
YouTube and twitch chat will try to
answer questions to the best of our
ability I haven't actually played the
DLC yet so we'll we'll see how this goes
yes I was exciting when the fans and
viewers gets to see guys like us
experiencing this content fresh
I can bump up our game audio for now
yeah as we get through this
oh hey there Manon Ezra see de una poca
Cocteau Nazi I mu ru ey3 testa Hanzo
dono
Ottavia dolana yo kenka you re s semana
would score a date in kata Hey he only
I'm Asura
someone you might know from the bingo
game han xue features as a supporting
character go to the email at Ino you can
even transform yourself into him I think
if you've got enough worries
oh yeah hot rakia tena koe I hear noises
in each car Adama Salmonella or ei no
kotoba mo meat curry muscle and that's
Masamune that a son I believe
mathematical it's out today oh shoot oh
gosh no rookie re to you was homie me
neither star Korea in a coat oh ho
Ayakashi not Oh Tori neat R&D vasudeo
sorrow CA no no Ava Marie chose de Caro
Coco's okay oh no you know children
attend karuizawa yo motorist llamo she
Ramos Aaron yo car Oh hiya Cassie no
koto dome I'm Anita say Bob Olsen is
Shira Co Coty's can I do currently
Hanzo hakuna mutata Ayakashi otaku
stutters right me squilliam haha cinemas
oh ho yeah I'm dead no way no way no no
ha sido toy you canö made anita kimono
yo Oh we'll meet oh [ __ ] whoa
he's probably got like a guardian it's
my guess there's two new guardians and
DLC as well as a new weapon and some new
armor apparently you don't usually see
title screens for their own DLC
all right yeah swag it out
those are all the events that happens
prior to this
once you're supposed to be dead no an
accent
we did technically kill him or like I
don't know help them out
but are beyond idea supid you are
[Music]
[Music]
studies JD guys a lot this is out today
you guys can go get it if you have the
game or if you want to also oh okay I
guess we just got him for free
Grady used to have them right or was he
just like part of the fun
he's part of the plot I think I never I
know I save her boy alright lady did
later Dave you don't sceeto me
so no more take you what they were
essentially sure so cool
totally yeah
you are a huge skater like Angus can
have as much content as any like one
region like an e like don't our that'd
be great yeah
this must be like new yokai too so that
should be good
I've seen the weapon it's like called a
node achi I think that's why not the
right pronunciation was like a big
two-handed sword the problem is I expect
myself into two-handed swords and our
sorry dual wield swords rather and I'm
like seventy into skill so yeah we can
check out so apparently you can trade in
for more the female characters or
something like that I think what the
glory points I'm not sure we'll see oops
that could be a lie though is C oh there
you go
hashtag blame I don't think I don't
think these two were available before
but yeah what's up - oh you can turn
down the gameplay a little bit now now
that we're out of the cutscenes um I
doubt I can level up um just worst case
you can reroll oh okay I was not to say
I was like I leveled my cot oh you
better not be oh you can have two
Guardians now interesting who do I want
to have as my second guardian I haven't
leveled any of the other ones though how
would that work in terms of activating
them because I have no idea that's new
um I have no idea this is I did not
expect that I'd find at least guardian
spirits had some really awesome
character designs yeah one raccoon with
a temple on this bag this one yeah not a
common ton of key uh I don't know man I
don't have like any bonuses with
anything though anyways I don't know
pick one or check and pick one I don't
care as my secondary I think I'm only
missing like one guardian
the base game you have a preference what
were you using I was using Tamaki oh you
are okay all right we'll use tonic even
I know yeah I don't I need a million to
level up I guess we can enhance the
tanuki right do this anymore now do to
do plus four to look Dan cost a hundred
thousand all right fine
where the stream
all right let's go we should probably
speed this up one oh I can't oh you know
why I haven't saved any Kodama in this
region huh
all right 150 not bad I'm like 130
something I feel less bad probably won't
get rekt too hard hopefully oh the twin
Thunder Doge dang I Morgan my bed I'll
change it later that came in a little
slow but we are on delay so it is what
it is that's how you pronounce it Doge
Doge Doge I'm gonna go with those yeah
so you reviewed this game right you
enjoyed it quite a bit it was quite the
trial by fire having it be my first
review assignment when working with
joining folk GameSpot full time even
though I had logged in about 45
freelance reviews rape smut under my
belt so yes it was probably like the
hardest 9 out of 10 of the game was
really hard but it wasn't hard giving it
a 9 out of 10 all right so how do I swap
the Guardians
because right now you see it right it's
in the top left yeah you see I just
don't know what the by my way to change
it and
who you get it right off the bat the new
weapon all right we got equipped any
weapon hey I didn't think they would
just give it to us yes secondary spirit
is new to DLC how is it oh wait we can
order it newest oh there it is there you
go good thing I have no familiarity
that's fine oops and so is this oh yeah
that's the new weapon you doubt the
Adachi I'm probably not as proficient
with it as a two-handed weapon there's
fine you skills for it to normal arrows
oops hope the other guy doesn't aggro me
head to the right okay
hey it's got some reach all right that
was midstance and we need some skills
probably got something a little bit
actually I have a lot of skills good
thing I saved them all good job ah right
see whoops I got a dead edited ah over
here
alright so use the hilt hey where are
all the moves you use your key pulse
regularly I try to hmm whoo I don't like
the ones where you have to guard though
now what's at the end of the combo okay
we'll get that that's this one high
stance sure sure you get that too
oops
[Music]
we're the bleach fans
zangetsu outtake as on get see sure buy
that increase damaging your share of
bleach ah I watched I watched a lot of
bleach then I read the rest of the manga
but it was not as good
later on it could have ended after Aizen
in my opinion for anyone that actually
understands what I'm talking about quick
attack
oops dang it my bed sorry I probably
should have did this before you guys
checked it got on stream here now that I
think about it but what's this melee
mastery I don't have barehanded attack
so it's got to be that then I guess
what's this oh we're getting that oh boy
forget in that one all right whatever
all right we're going to use the sword
and hope for the best
oh crap pinky balls like an amateur he's
not letting me do the the move we just
learned Oh
let's see what the finishing move is
that did no damage I felt weak I don't
know that's a pretty it's pretty fun
weapon um I like the faster weapons
myself you used mainly the kusarigama
right yeah a little I don't even know
how to classify it as it's like a ninja
train and the ninja chain I guess yeah
that's good way so there's a guy over
there oh I just woke up a guy with dual
wheels also I don't do a good job of
like switching chances you mid combo oh
I do it really Dark Souls II where like
I just do like one combo well I love
switching stances and then I and then I
just switched stances later if it's a
more beneficial at that time I
definitely like switching stances
if I'm familiar with the enemy man like
I got some wheat gear it's purple
wait it's purple higher than green
alexhuchet
I don't remember the color I haven't
played in a while to be honest
Oh No what is that oh that's new that is
me Oh h-hey that's not cool because
cheesin how does that even work
maybe he's [ __ ] a depend a lot on
this long that's not even that's not
even a thing though and whatever I think
he'll probably be weak super up close
Oh doing no damage hmm maybe I can hide
behind this rock
oh no what is that Oh hurts a lot
Connor if it just does work though Z is
he Oh got it
this is your question
Oh No get out of there
well I got lucky there don't lie okay
cuz alright that was interesting does
this not have kick as a thing who do you
know I'm talking about like because kick
gets rid of key that's true stab
does that do ooh breakdancing akechi
you're implying that you what you
something about the game made you give
up on it hmm
hitsugaya fan and reach her and they
Twitter the chat there when hit the guy
goes like crazy god mode though Oh next
next shrine we have found no Kodama we
are failing right now we go or mainly
I'm failing because you're just watching
so you can't fail if there's that one
there's that one item or we could
actually hear nearby Kodama oh yeah oh
is the does wearing the Hat give you a
thing where like it pings the map yeah
forget like like you see that that yeah
maybe someone in chat knows oh there's a
guy with a gun
weird
oh that was the that was the move there
though the combo over there oh I tried
to switch stances there and I pretty
much got punished for it that's why
what's your default stance I like mid a
lot but that's just me
oh he's got a helmet no Pedro 666 asking
how many DLC levels will there be oh no
I think there's three DLC right so
potentially 300 that's what you're the
turtle guys do you guys all have a lot
of Wow
like your old buddy review and I bet
some dude is hiding behind that tree so
what if we just snipe them oh that did
not kill him surprisingly no
these guys are tough oh he's going on
here but why are you rubbing a head hole
paralytic
hey cat Oh paralyzed
paralyzed again and it's super annoying
there's usually the fun part about these
PLC's is that they all developers are an
opportunity to change things up like
that may not necessarily be for the best
alright there's death number one I blame
it on the weapons though I'm assuming
you have this stag he that could he has
the Kodama sent you know what you guys
got to see that weapon plenty nice dodge
well cat I didn't want to jinx things
but this is actually my first time for
unquote health hosting big spot
thankfully I'm up the one playing so
well I'll be forever indebted to
for being my cheerleader during the
surge alive stream I honestly didn't
think that I could build that boss Adam
yeah it's all about the non panic right
right I would like no health left in its
final form you haven't seen what it's so
much easier with the weapons that are
strong oh there's a Kadam right there at
least a swamp isn't poisonous
yeah like Dark Souls would be here
remember that one level in Dark Souls 3
where it's like a red cap a shield place
there really dark swamp there's like
those frog guys that like paralyze you
and it is swampy no yet or
yeah those guys it's near the Ferren
Castle I think super annoying though why
cos that's super seed oh no he was going
all have yet has he uh have you ever
experienced that before what he does a
thousand-year pain on you he'll go up
behind you to stick his fingers up your
butt no I would have remembered that
okay well don't get grabbed by a turtle
as you might do that to you all the
turtles have encountered have like tried
to run away oh yeah because they got the
the loot the loot guys like the goblins
or whatever for on those little stone
guys in Dark Souls
Bob Jones would like to remind you to
dodge to dodge we just Yolo with the
dual wheels like this just keep pressing
square and then stuff happens more dudes
over there there is a yokai over here I
bet you it's like another new yokai oh
wait I just got a turtle's attention oh
that's so cheap oh you know what we
should do
later this keeps happening oh [ __ ] um
put on like a paralysis charm oh he went
for it again always equipped one are you
one of those purists that isn't using
the slowdown talisman oh I have it
equipped I didn't really use it so I'll
be honest
personally I haven't used that many I
don't use that many talismans and I
don't have that much uh which would call
its sorry trying to think and do
something the same time here on me oh I
don't have that much all meal as what I
meant to say I don't even have like a
green paralysis whatever it's fine
did you go heavy and oh these guys going
these guys suck oh yeah don't worry
dual wield proficiency oh this is like
shortcut oops
yeah to avoid all the turtles probably
later always gotta get your shortcuts
guys alright so there is a youkai I
think it's a new yokai oh okay I hate
these guys
this is your favorite level that was you
guys yeah Eric got this uh look over my
shoulder and I was playing the fat one
section for like what felt like two days
okay yeah well I remember you
little cut oh oh
there-there Wincott oh one charge from
that guy this is going to be tough with
those two guys throwing the para
paralytic stuff
no-no-no that's second death
someone can keep track that was dumb I
saw how much Sam and I had that was
really dumb so far been enjoying the mix
of new and familiar enemies yeah the guy
with the lung the big snake neck was
pretty tough so far it was just the
turtles and that guy I think
is what I do I just mash till they're
out of stamina uh it's kind of like
Onimusha there's some things I would say
that are like Onimusha they're not not
all of it though I mean I'd say both uh
both this game Andalusia series do a
pretty good job in interpreting
creatively the giving their own spin on
the designs of yokai I could agree with
that I do not want to deal with that guy
guy sucks umbrella guy
oh there's two of them now we're just
washing
so fire bucket I believe the season pass
has this DLC plus two more guilty I
believe that's correct
now it's like a really quick second
there to execute did not do that though
I guess you give for farm breadkappa
shells this way
what's up curtain tom there's your
shoutout second your girlfriend oh she's
here to troll me okay I think I've seen
her in your Disneyland tweets yep
you want a free burrito give me
alright that's kinda not this time
so I feel like Oh
and uh neo previously there were only a
few times all know where you got
surrounded and this seems like one of
those cases it seems like the easiest
way for them to make the game harder is
just add at all are you not
Oh doc can I hit him in the head
what do you have a follow-up
hmm just die you're out of stamina nice
okay I am the red kappa cutter I guess I
forgot what's the benefit of the red
kappa i don't know i think it's just a
new material i'm not sure that i didn't
look in the inventories i have not
experienced any glitches yet fire bucket
i don't think i experienced any glitches
in this game personally i don't know
about you Miguel did you oh not that I
recall
I want to pray no one thanked oh wait
youkai don't respawn though so guess the
turtles would so we have that there's
clearly a shortcut there we just got
kicked that ladder down so oh hello
oh no snakehead guy
oh okay so if you do a high attack on
the other head
the yokai head it does more damage
there's something very gratifying about
fighting an enemy enough times to know
their weakness based on your stance all
right
dodging the tree tongue oh there's two
so it's a regroup okay I guess that
doesn't work no more cheese in it with
the gun oh my god
you used a cannon right yeah Hank any or
the big cannon
yeah the big candidate yeah then
poisoned Oh
[Applause]
okay not cool
at least somehow the other ones not a go
as I say that
alright we got it no problem nailed it
only took three elixirs or whatever it
was oh man
you ever have this problem where you
can't pick anything up because you have
too much I'm a hoarder in life too
all right we should figure out how to
swap the spirits so we could charge up
the other one at some point
oh yeah hey Andre I need to yeah I need
to figure out how to switch it though
it's a problem cuz like clearly I can do
it there right you got their arrows too
but now you have to hit something else
too Swami it's not up down left right
and it's not the stance buttons it's not
doing anything
oh it's a l2 oh did we just lose all the
little hobbits wick should swap it back
I can't right now I don't think oh yes
okay Miguel I'm gonna what you really
upset I'm in a second I think it wasn't
a church back up I think that if you
switch a party rug oh no okay
all right all right look has look as I
saved you
nothing went wrong there
the other guys normal oh there's a
caning guy we got kill the candy guy
first 100% one thing I thought the
studio could have done a better job on
is a greater variety of music because
I've listened to this pepper yeah well
you're very for Sona too though this
very somber track feels like it fit in
like every other mission
you don't like this tranquil music oh
you're like killing all the people it's
really very sad oh why okay this guy
clearly does not give a crap about my
moves
usually the dual wheel just got the
stagger action going
okay he transforms I think I agree with
you sir
what's that there's honestly t mean just
best game since Ninja Gaiden 2 to the
office that's fair alright you know that
stuff I can't pick up all right
that's a youkai probably he's probably
guarding the shortcut I guess I don't
need to dodge Bob I'm just getting at
getting to dodge for sure okay
and so
Wow that sucks
oh my god it was a lot of guys it's a
lot of guys to have to go back and kill
now I underestimated the turtle
apparently that one move is enough to
kill me or like half life so we'll just
play it a lot safer and though I have
like way less elixirs as I say back
I guess the trick is to be close to
those guys but the only problem is uh if
the human part of them actually swings a
weapon oh there's a second guy isn't
there
yeah there goes all my I'm gonna fight
that way ah wait loose James isn't Lucy
James no it's not but Liz James is a
pretty I think she watches a fair
mushroom so welcome back Liz thanks for
tuning in thanks to all of you for
tuning in and watching the guy horrible
deaths like I thought for sure I mean if
the Liz if the persona Katherine costume
DLC was more substantial I thought they
would have formed that team yeah
I think I'm actually I was moving down
so that wasn't using Eric should go to
an easier area this is the easiest or
the first area of Appeals to say whose
statement he's talking trash bob jock
Dodge Bob Jones Bob Jones pretty
standard Bob move
oh no it's not okay then okay all right
I'm sorry I lost count are we at five
yeah we're five we're vodka thanks for
keeping me honest though
[Applause]
why
hmm dude where's the where's the elixirs
off these guys it doesn't do it either
huh interesting
here we'll play the long con as to not
die what's up bill lambda P that's been
djenka see you should be able to hit
that that's
genka our mario kart champion that is
correct
that's stuck on the tree trunk do you
have anything okay you know what
whereas I don't have a green sphere you
pretty you're pretty proficient on the
Spears yes feel like a spear would be
good but maybe I don't have one that
that's that good yes Yukimura you have
to finish it
I believe it seems that way because you
couldn't access it on your account when
we're checking oh I'm in heist and I
should win this level this area is
grated at a little Hubbard and I don't
know how they do that when I got
Oh God uh that's green I don't have time
to pick it up so I have no mori elixirs
I feel confident
it's fine who needs elixirs we need that
shortcut though real bad just smoke some
of these guys in the head see that guy I
guess you can tell like he's like one of
those monsters because you can't
headshot him thank you can you have the
yellow dot earlier this is the hardest
part playing an FPS good why where is
the hey there you go
headshot and then quite a faceoff I know
right but then it doesn't work on the
other guy and then that guy's a snake
guy too
uh their shrine over here Oh Oh God oh
man there's a big yokai over there oh no
all right well best wishes to me
maybe we'll slow him down I think that
slowed them down no
nothing huh oh that just like less
damage them hmm
the slowdown talisman looks like a dude
carrying a sec nice that's good to know
so is it in your other set of shortcuts
no cuz I don't have it probably you know
what maybe they're just tryin over here
Oh
shortcut that's the door go go go
this is how you got do it guys you just
got cheese it just got cheese it Oh see
you don't need you don't need it look
Circe's also Oh what I could tell them
stuff but I'm not going to ok wait Oh No
why don't get elixirs in here you don't
replenish them at the shrines
oh no it's odd I think maybe after X
amount of time I don't know Oh sense for
me coming that's why I kill this guy
I'll get some
proper little waggy they webbed up are
you excited for prey it has gotten some
Bioshock comparisons
that was official I was here right maybe
I should have sold something that I
definitely could have got some back by
sold how is that oh that's why okay
like how's that not headshotting oh how
is he not dead oh you can target the
other guy okay
six seven which one is it Nick we're at
seven ah this is playstation I didn't
see who asked what this is playstation
oh that guys still there or maybe we
just walk really quietly he'll never
hear us wait he's a yokai though right
shouldn't have done yeah but it wasn't
one of those clouded ones that you know
on okay all right here
[Music]
see you got that time crab
elixir please sign an elixir oh yes oh
wait my elixir short quick you take him
out or something
oh god how do I said shortcuts again I
lied to you I - oh yeah you said I
picked up a lick sir
did it not my crazy
oh you're sort of the newest dude I
swear I picked up Alex I saw - you guys
saw that yes that's all right there just
said it looks rx1 where is it shortcut
item all right I guess we're just not
getting elixirs all right cool good
chats the book I don't know there was
this thing where like you stop getting
elixirs at some point but I don't recall
why sounds unfair and it sounds pretty
bare
No Oh swore he's gonna hit you with that
that's correct
flopping up someone says bug I don't
think it's a bug yet to restart the game
elixir it doesn't restock in this
mission I'm thinking elixir doesn't
restock on this mission that's what I
think I mean what I can do now that
we're here is I can sell a bunch of
stuff and see if we got any elixirs
though oh yeah right I got ya good price
already so like okay how do I post
select
I'm a hoarder
oh is that new let's stay in cleaver
that looks cool all right so all right
technically I should have lower elixirs
oops
exceeds the limit and should be my story
up there I got three all right three is
better than none and we're totally
avoiding that guy cuz F that guy you
really do look like a demon from behind
me playing the Nobunaga gear all right
oh yeah
okay okay now my four so I guess maybe
it was a little bulky maybe now I can
get elixirs I don't know
all outward
I'll kill me for you throws all right
yep plan does game so I still do to
Skyrim mod reviews now we don't love
note use low stance to set our own blaze
make quick look okay I'll try I just
wonder why ya just want that fire
Oh
seem to be pretty decent strategy all
right we're getting elixirs again that's
good oh this guy's new what is this guy
why does he smell so crazy I don't like
it
oh he's got a whirlwind oh yeah how you
like my my jokes cut though son Oh what
what's going on right now
how's weird you can feel it but my
controller was going crazy and I
couldn't move it's the demon Harvester
yeah whatever he died what if I just
fell what if you cut down that bridge
like in Dark Souls no that's not a thing
what if I just fell there though well
like what if I just run to this shrine
because shrines are good all right
nasty things a head says Abdullah no oh
I'm so close to leveling up yeah
whatever doesn't matter
wait does that door open if I doesn't
I'm guessing now yeah did you see that
corpse at the ball of the cliff yeah
over here right I think you got to get
there from this side though yeah I don't
think no I think there's yeah there's a
ladder there we got to get inside though
apparently there's nasty things ahead
I'm looking forward to it
oh hello always be checking boxes the
more Kodama the more like elixir did you
start off with and stuff right think
like off leave so
that guy seems unfazed the Scarecrow Oh
Club nub it is not open world oh but
it's pretty easy
to jump in and out of chapters yes
here so sorry no yes you have to clear
two main game
set them all on fire all right
oh I hear akadama oh you know what it's
just be a shrine hey I never really
liked exploring but then I can't help
myself okay there's another one of those
big dudes lookit let's get out of there
it almost reminds me of that ninja level
which are called ninja town and what if
you could go through the wall that would
be the cheapest
no just kill was that slender vertebra
take attack down oh he's got two
cleavers oh the bad time for a look here
yeah
oh that's what he did to me like glue
like chakra or whatever the bad chakra I
don't know that guy didn't seem that bad
come here to the other guy but the other
guy had boss music there really nothing
here
Oh big box Oh mimic mimic stupid raccoon
box oh no oh you're at a scam too bro
you are nothing but a poor version of me
that's fine as much as I would like to
pick up the green stuff I want to have
to throw stuff away waste your guys's
time wasting a enough time just dying
will there be more mess Effect Andromeda
videos oh maybe it's hard to say I mean
not in our immediate picture I don't
think in our immediate future now again
thank you guys all for tuning in
watching me and Miguel watching me die a
decent amount of times not too many at
times but enough times
well parse I sympathize if I picked if I
start playing this game again I probably
won't be so hot myself also translate
transitioning from near to neo is very
jarring considering the varying speed
and pace of both games
yeah I haven't played you in a while
last game I guess it was dark souls i
was playing Zelda and then playing Zelda
the Dark Souls is really hard actually
because the buttons are like way
different sometimes when we're reviewing
these games the last thing we want to do
after we review is play the game again
so I haven't touched this since the
review you jump down here and fight me
then interesting getting o base of the
controller you can get up to that guy
Oh Carter says you don't have to find
the mimics you can just have you can
just have to copy their remote gestures
and they'll leave you alone that is true
I believe but I fight everything usually
that's my ninja way as Naruto would say
but oh
Theo peeler okay so his his horn is is a
weakness
kind of like the other yokai
I don't know goop we'll find out what
how many levels and areas of the Steel's
yeah I have no idea I'm just trying to
get through this one
okay look at different okay oh he's got
to do a wheel why does he just stand
still like that sure does he only fight
in this area
looks like the saw guy a little bit
no I'll come back then I hit him in the
face
you know magic about a pan watched a
single episode of Naruto or bleach
you're missing out yeah I think in every
stream I should just confess something a
pop-culture haven't I
earlier in the stream I was talking Rob
found out I didn't watch Toy Story yeah
he's all this bad
but you've watched too I'm going to
watch three
oh you watch three but not one in two oh
do I really want to go up here to fight
on this city even worth it I don't feel
like it's worth it
oh my god holy of them just doing their
thing
barbecuing oh they all come alright
sometimes in life you've got a run to an
area where you're going to get screwed
at call you around the corner don't know
it doesn't matter but that's new Armour
I feel like you think they'll chase me
while I'm trying to drop an item to pick
up an item probably
so Naruto is was a very log shows and
our COO is still around right well
boruto is out now okay so there's a
bridge to go over there but there's
another big dude ah not good to me get
over what do you think of like the
environment so far it's kind of the same
as most neo most of neo the only
difference so far that's good is there's
new monsters but I don't feel like it
feels like it's like a Dark Souls dlc
where there's some new monsters but then
that's it you know wow wow
he'll be Legolas or no add Nietzsche
they really do call me Legolas I missed
them twice that's why I was making a
badger oh why do they come
gotta hope for the best
oh oh he picked me up I was like what
happened
what is that what the crap is it okay
okay okay reset reset the fight we set
the fight leave me alone oh look you're
just gonna help it someone else saw you
this is good this is good this is good
this is what we want
the hut is my sanctuary oh no it's not
you can funnel em in like a first-person
shooter it's fine
oh it's like when you play left for dead
you know you get them all in like one
line
[Music]
give me that free no wow
and so I was trying to get the little
like invulnerability frames but this is
really stressful oh how am I not dead
okay okay oh okay
I think surviving this this fight here
is an achievement in itself I don't know
how to not going to ask why
your elixirs give them to me
we almost spammed circle too much and
got the god damn it
oops just got a just just a hoarder you
know oops I forgot to take did we say we
were going to an hour or nightmare
somewhere in the hour to 90 minutes
we'll see how far we get how are we
doing right now we are at 2 o'clock okay
so we are at an hour yeah alright so
hopefully I can get to where I need to
get to here that's not there oh not like
these on bed all right I'm really hoping
those three guys at the top are really
not there I'm gonna be really sad if
they're there like really I think
they'll be there thanks me go
oh great he had wood on him there there
of course why wouldn't they be there
right
oh hello other friends
yeah I do hate that about anime how much
a lot of these long-running shows of
filler Oh
one piece was the one that I feel like
didn't have that much filler but you so
they're already it overall thousand
episodes are they that was it yeah
they're close I don't um they have that
filler they catch up to the manga too
quickly yeah you know what I suck yeah
once you climb a ladder climb a ladder
yeah you don't know how to Eric when you
initially downloaded this did it did you
see like a progress bar or because it
like seemed like it downloaded and
immediately ah there was a good progress
where I don't think it downloaded right
away God quickly quickly
we're like nine deaths now nine mmm it's
fine
hi guy the house
hi other guys
you pack really only 750 yokai over
there
hmm it was hard thank you
Kemetic new have you beaten the game the
main game me someone is talking about
how he can't access it
yeah oh you know what he has to do to
possibly like I said oh she's in my new
game I had to change it back to like
normal cuz I wasn't far enough where he
needed to be
so yeah you either have to beat it or at
least set it back to where you need to
go get to right there's a dude there's
totally Oh
was there a ladder that Eleanor's a
shortcut and how big is this level box
we beat the game months ago okay um if
you new game+ you might have to go back
to your older save that's why my
favorite animations no this is gonna
suck you know all in there's a freaking
rifle guy could think it looks haha
sneaky I didn't even spot on my just
anger good oops
animations looping I can't hit him like
this
yes Oh No a little side stretcher Oh
awkward
[Laughter]
well enough I am excited for red just
started playing the first red one hip
eleven oh yeah I think it's 11 maybe 12
I don't know
oh man why guys all the way over there
and then like there's this dude that
dude that's actually not okay
oh there's no ladders here either oh and
there's a guy that shoots a gun over
there oh there's a letter okay
oh not today he says dude what the crap
what is going on here trying to choose
my way through here you should use this
Suzaku guardian spirit um maybe okay
okay we for sure know we can run by all
this okay now technically run by this
stuff
then another dude that guy let's see if
we can cheese up a ladder here go go go
hoho yikes we go down this ladder
I don't care about fall damage then we
kick this shortcut I think this is
shortcut yep yeah that's how you do it
you know you don't own oh hello
that guy's got the goodies he's the kind
that has the goodies I'm gonna die try
to kill this guy all night ha boy
okay
oh oh I know it's like jammies in my
camera
no Kyle this DLC is not free fortunately
not well I mean neo the game itself was
like such a long game I felt like that
it was like totally worth it the green
thing forth life all right
wait there's nothing over here except
that guy oh this guy's here though just
got beaten another path nearby
just to guess
well there was that uh this shortcut
here but that's all that there was for
that and I don't think any of this opens
up Oh nailed it there's a house we're
basically trying to get to a block right
I'm paralyzed
like that umbrella on fire okay
wait is it just another shortcut
eventuates just to open the main door
that's another shortcut okay here we go
I think the bosses oh yeah that's
totally a boss huh
all right well give me half an hour to
try to feel boss we still have two
million on Rita oh it's a big box here
though big boxes nothing summer inner
candles great you think it's a boss
Miguel yes so you think I should
probably go back to the shrine huh for
what to level up oh yeah I can then come
back yet
all right all right
I think it's last time my name is boss
time what should I do here look at my 70
skill I like even numbers all right
whatever let's go let's go oh man I only
have three elixirs because I only have
three Kodama you got it you think so
okay
I believe we need thank you all right
let's watch a cutscene
is that my son Oh No
[Music]
centipede god that's so great
cool all right this boss is tough uh
then again I only tried for 15 minutes
okay I didn't think that was going to
happen there's a lot of damage
it's quite a lot of damage you were able
to deal some damage
yeah but how much did I really deal
you're welcome
you guys should get the skill for the
bill Thomas felt signup ha ha I think I
be I think I picked up the souls [ __ ] ah
the sign of the cost I think I have that
but I'm not sure that's a nice character
design and what ok whoo let's gosh on
the butt okay maybe we don't care about
the souls cuz we
Oh
okay
do they always have a weak spot right
there's always a weak spot where the
hell is a weak spot
not yet I always use it to to kill the
oh wow
many tricks apparently he throws weapons
um okay
do you think that maybe it's the
centipede head
there's always something right I feel
like every neo boss I've fought always
has something like I don't know what it
is
there's always something that they like
but I find really fascinating are those
bosses that have a weak sides I'm
guessing I'm not necessarily the arm
that isn't the centipede Oh
okay okay okay okay so he does this
twirly
I'm dead ah at least show me the
animation what does he do after that
okay okay I should use it as I die wait
what it's the tail really hmm
it's the tail we'll try the tail it's
gonna be hard though it's the kind of
interesting thing about this boss is you
get fixated with like the centipede arm
and then you don't think about his
actual like just like swinging arm and
then you get punished
considering the centipede harvest of the
trolls
you uh okay too proud to use the the
slowdown the sloth not necessarily okay
what I need to do though I feel like is
my armor I'm very lightweight right now
I could I could wear some medium armor
you know what I'm saying I have any
medium armor not really huh
we're in one piece of heavy
oh yeah
you know what it's fine it's fine we
just gotta get good Miguel you know
that's what it is I just can't get hit
more than twice the right arm is the
weak point
I don't know all right
I'm not going to let me no wait sir
it's not as weak it's not as definitely
not his right arm I don't even know what
he's doing who I look through that
it's not his tail all right circular one
then that one then I can heal hopefully
okay oh that's up feel like being close
to him is not bad though I'm gonna
eventually die though
he doesn't know what to do ah I feel
like we got a clue there I feel good I
feel good about it
yeah the missions like 150 I think one
tens ma v doable I don't know there's
something I'm noticing how you play
fundamentally but I mean different than
I do is like ie I prioritize healing
above all else party
I just feel like this guy doesn't give
me the time to breathe to like he'll
like see I just tried to do it there but
that was a mistake cuz then okay so
every boss is kind of like I don't have
like sixteen Desna um I feel like every
boss has like two different mechanics of
like when you're close and when you're
far away right like there he's never
gonna throw the weapons at me right but
staying close there I feel like is the
way to go
the problem is I just don't know when
it's safe to heal so like I don't I feel
like pretty confident when we're trying
to like brawl and stuff but when I try
to stop to heal I feel like I have to
run away what the hell is my oh god that
like hurts so much
can't be greedy can't be greedy that's
what we're trying to find out jack yeah
I'm guessing there's at least two bosses
right um I feel like the whole premise
is like what's his name it's a oh that
sucks
um got a is like the big dot like this
is not the guy you're like chasing right
oh no I think I was paralyzed with my
own fear look 15 there's four bosses
someone says try to dash around and keep
slicing yeah I'm trying I have to just
not worry about my life as much I guess
and just I don't know but I feel like
when you have like a he's going to have
like a Phase two right most of these
bosses have a Phase two oh now I don't
even have guardian spirit okay you know
what though it's actually better
actually better that I don't I'm amazed
Thank You Jackie the bright side no
because now I won't be so fixated on
picking on my stupid guardian spirit and
then I'll just earn the guardian spirit
and then be able to use it by the end
because I never like really using the
guardian spirit in the beginning but you
have told me that you are able to
guardian spirit more than once in one
fight I usually use it to finish the
boss off so
I think after that that's probably safe
Oh
okay now oh no no
no I got stuck in the corner I doubt the
wrong way okay yeah I feel I feel like
it's a it's starting to start and feel
it out I feel like what's gonna happen
though is paced who's gonna come and
there's like figuring out that part of
it too
see it's kind of like Dark Souls once
you kind of figure out the boss
mechanics it's not so bad but you kind
of have to figure them out a little bit
nope that was such a nice opening move I
know
beat him already so he can look at other
world yeah I'd love to just beat him ah
you know alright gotta be more patient
can't choose yellow he clearly will
punish and he looks like you can kill me
and my current life because I don't have
that much life I'm like two hits so
alright
out of all these love enough I think
both came I are big blood-borne fans yep
let the other guy play No
huh I like how you quickly dismissed
that one
why does that hit twice he's got too
many moves I'll let him play if he wants
to play I don't know combats ten times
where the dark oh yeah I guess I could
see that combat being better than dark
souls do you feel like the comments
Bears and Dark Souls I think it's a
cop-out fun I think it's like apples and
oranges thanks oh God
I mean I'm look at you now and I'm like
man I can go for some Dark Souls and
it's okay
okay well use talismans not enough
damage yeah I don't have enough
talismans though I don't have that much
invested into you oh me oh so like gonna
be hard for me too
I like to cheese I love this lock all
right let's see if I can if I have
enough on my odo to slop it I've never
sloth any boss though let him try for
one that's great feels like you're
cheating it does it yeah oh but then at
the level it too probably
oops
all right where's oh that's it I pass it
there slow okay
I need to clear the mission the Omni
hood nevermind
you're getting owned yeah I'm getting on
you're never gonna beat him with Sophie
Alex yes I am yes I am Ivan all you have
to do is get good you got your moments
dude I can't even get hit is the problem
at least not by a combo he doesn't have
any warning signs on the spin attack
I mean I could try shooting this combat
weak weakness thing talisman on it but I
don't think it's going to do what we
need to do
oh I didn't want to say anything I know
I know it's okay I I uh I actually hit X
there and I feel like I ran right into
his tail I was like oh god I need to
heal guys I need a he'll see you don't
need it you don't need that video like
serious dude halfway down one elixir all
right and I was like watching his ki I
was like oh man he's about to get
staggered I'm gonna guess I was like
Miguel don't say anything
that damn oh thanks Manoj I did great
that time at least fine where tries and
he gets he thinks all right damn thanks
fine wait rise so that really means for
more tries okay okay okay I got a do GN
right he's a he's got faith in me you
got faith in me to Miguel
absolutely like me guys anything you
guys have all people deserve it on no
but my corner I think you like the Lord
has to do more of those jump attacks
leave himself quite open
he's much open here
Oh God see
can't get hit by the sword because that
just leads to what I should be doing to
actually is I should be kicking him to
lower the key I think Ivan if you've
beaten the game on you and you gave Plus
if you go to the map and then you hit
change you can go back to I think the
first like your first playthrough and
then you can pick the the new region
like arrow
okay yeah I can't I can't get out of
that can't disagree with you Jan you'll
never beat this boss because he doesn't
have a Pepsi
Thanks iron line I think you'll get it
in five well I only have like two or
three from that five now but sorry we
have five minutes left
oh we're gonna get we're not stopping
till he dies okay we go actually I don't
know we'll see well base it on progress
really had him that one time though and
I choked it oh that's new why didn't
that work oh that's such a creepy ass
like
you'll let me know
oh no I saw when he swung I don't have
any so the problem is I don't have that
many talismans or enough on me oh and I
didn't do the Adept thing so I don't
have any to use on him and I also don't
feel like there's that much time to like
cast anything on him um if I could be
wrong
obviously I pretty much played this game
like it was like a blood war game where
I went like all like melee Oh God
Wow no I was me does my fault
we regressed we de volved I felt like
we're reaching Super Saiyan and then we
like we need a Zen zubeen I need you
guys to give me your power like Goku
Chan will channel the power of the
spirit bomb
the overhead swing hurt so bad try to
dashboard them back will swing I could
still use buffs yes if I had any buffs
I need slot yeah I know Miguel already
asked and then I said oh I didn't do owe
me ah depth
blocking more keep rotating y-yeah block
blocking actually is probably good call
for the the high swing though that I
don't dispute Oh
or he could just spin me and ground
pound me oh oh cool
oh cool yeah what do you want us to do
that information yeah you ever feel like
um like when you start off that you just
want to die and just start over
oh you're like I feel like I good when I
get hit I just like kind of just want to
die but then like I'm like oh people are
watching so I should probably try to
live what happened to five tries Jan you
gave up on me
we're in front of Tony Hawk damn it it
went from 20 minutes or five five tries
five more tries to oh my god
like that yeah yeah get it
we just really need to refocus all right
I'm going to give myself a hard cutoff
of at the latest 2:45 so that's 15
minutes if we don't get it we don't get
it there's it's not blood-borne you can
block the attack yes you can't block the
attempt well technically there was like
one shield in blood-borne that did
nothing for you oh hello
[Music]
I got a I think I just have to be super
patient at the dodge and wait till he's
done doing a combo then attack that
escalated quickly
I know it's frustration
well
he is exactly like a diamond Lobster see
that's what happens when you're far from
him
I just wanted to heal and then like
maybe I can get it off and then he'll
throw the thing and then I'll dodge it
but no offense a lot so I've had some
boss fights in both like neo and maybe
some Dark Souls were I would I would
actually look at the footage of my most
successful fights and see if I could
find some clues in there
just block air yeah you only lose on
rivet I'm Rita when you die
you used to lose like more durability
and stuff in this game in the like alpha
days but it's not so punishing anymore
thanks CJ it is kind of hard no I know
CJ fan so don't pick up my guardian
spirit
I have gotten him to 50% one time and
the run was looking real good and then I
like rolled into his a it's so good I
didn't say a damn tail you're getting it
now daddy board didn't wait by dashing
the side after yep
I just have to be patient I mean I think
if we just did nothing but try to wait
for his combo attacks and then only
attack then we could kill him but it's
gonna be like one of the slowest Oh God
oh how did that hit me
okay how's the time
rolled into his dam attack all right we
have no elixirs that's fine who need
them
glad you're enjoying it CJ
I might be one tonight persona 5 is not
on pieces no should it dodge to the
right don't forget after a half healthy
gets harder yeah well we got him to half
didn't we did he did he actually get
harder because I didn't see it well he
didn't look like he was getting harder I
didn't see it I he didn't do it like he
didn't have the tell you know what I
mean Oh duh
I just want the - I don't want the roll
excuse okay 12 minutes 12 minutes this
is gonna be fine all right maybe we
should stop going hi Stan's not working
can you deflect them back into the
swords I don't
Oh fire bucket why did you dodge because
I didn't press X fast enough you roll in
high stance
that's probably why whatever thank you I
was in mixed answer that last time
stance
all right low stance we'll just
chocolate top the beat
but
we should have killed there
now's the time
oh that's new that's so new look at
Bella
what was that know what the his
centipede arm was going like Wiggly
crazy oh my goodness
did I notice you've been you've been a
lot more putting more effort and staying
on the side of the shore yeah because
when I went to the other side I ate it
from his a center caterpillar hand I'll
just stick with our strategy to go back
to high stance it's like a 72 hit combo
with pretty long range nice single -
right and kind of two pieces it's like
I'm pecking away at him with my low
stance
no it's over you just care I can't get
hit by that all right it's getting
better I didn't you did well enough that
you didn't even use any of your lick
sirs but I don't the thing is like I
don't even know oh man I've never been
able to really use my range weapon
against a boss it's like so sketchy like
I don't ever feel like there's enough
time they like actually attack with a
range weapon also because like they move
so much
I just wanted to elixir Miguel later
well no stay to his left side do the
left side was like so much more
dangerous I'll try the left side but
you'll see how much more dangerous it is
also it's like now that I have the
rhythm that I'm in I don't know if it's
so smart to break the rhythm
all right what's your idea so this is a
short talk to the boss that's true well
level of my 136 137 definitely stay on
the right
thank you dr. Fung yes good night Yuki
just stay on the right yeah I'm going
with stay on the right I'm pretty sure
that seemed I was like yeah all right
because the only thing he does really on
the right is a swing the sword you
ragdoll to my body how are we doing six
minutes
okay is that new armor no this is a
mostly Nobunaga armor or like demon I
forget what it's called
I have schools in six hours lazy to go
to bed that's not good
glad you're watching but I don't losing
sleep is Oh God
how cool
so just so you know I get staggered when
I get hit by his caterpillar arm that's
why I'm not moving he's like stuck there
for a second ah yeah you could block the
sword on the right yeah I'll try that
well I should really try that I keep
forgetting it's just not in my instinct
I'm just so used to dodging because the
like blood board and stuff like that
okay we'll try blocking because we know
he's going to do it right oh that's not
okay that took all my stamina
okay so I blocked it and try to get out
of the way of the combo I was pretty
rough
Oh
[Music]
how do you how did I give him the 50%
earlier with high stands it was only
high stance
you know only if we could look at the
tape the tape the tape will be there it
will be available later yeah
a few more minutes guys hopefully we get
them if not I apologize yeah
you
write it back
oh that's new that's Sonia that's the
stupid whippin it's like seven attacks
that one apparently sucks everything
that's going solo could you stay behind
him I can try but he eventually will
swing shot in the back there is explain
the melee mastery passive
so I think for at least do we hope the
sorts and you just get more damage if
you keep swinging
[Music]
that's right that's right whoo-ahh right
in the nick of time
oh I was like don't just just you got it
you got it
um you know what I was thinking this is
like the surge thank you for being there
for me we go this is a oh man
low stance and some patience so that was
the first mission give or take I guess
of neo TLC it's available today ps4 you
can download it my heart is racing right
now
as it should when you when you beat a
tough boss that has been tormenting
thank you Miguel you're welcome so much
this is your second stream today so I'm
sure you're a little tired but I want to
say thank you to all the viewers that's
stuck with me I don't mind the trolling
I'm glad you guys stayed and uh were
able to see that happen so stay tuned
the games fought for more Neal content
there's going to be a couple more DLC so
when those DLCs come out I'm sure you'll
see me and Miguel again maybe I'll force
Miguel to do it next time so I can just
read chat and and just send him my power
they'll give me some motivation to
continue on my neo save well there you
go then but thank you guys so much and I
think that's about it for us you got
anything else for them you go thanks
guys again this is the Neo DLC dragon of
the North out today so click that wave
goodbye
bye and then you get